il y a une nouveauté sur votre
smartphone de Samsung qui est vachement
bien c'est un mode Expert row pour la
photo avant c'est une application que
vous deviez télécharger à part et
aujourd'hui elle est inclut directement
ici grâce à one uy 5.0 vous allez dans
votre application photo et vous allez
sur plus juste à droite et vous allez la
trouver tout en haut espérons alors il
faut venir la télécharger moi j'ai déjà
fait et là vous aura accès à plein de
paramètres pour venir totalement
personnaliser votre expérience photo les
iso l'ouverture la balance des blancs
bref c'est très très bien l'histogramme
donc si vous êtes un amoureux ou une
amoureuse de la photo et bien vous avez
tout ici dans cette application qui est
regroupé sous l'application photo je
trouve ça très chouette d'ailleurs je
sais pas si ça peut vous intéresser si
vous l'utilisez marquez moi ça bien
évidemment dans les commentaires